2020 sera une nouvelle année de tous les
dangers pour l'amérique latine dans
plusieurs pays l'instabilité politique
est prise de pouvoir ou tentatives
qualifié de coup d'état par certains ont
marqué 2010 9 au venezuela par exemple
ce jus lutte sans merci entre le
président en exercice nicolas maduro à
la tête d'un pays accablé par les
sanctions américaines et le postulant
wan wide au 11 janvier 2019
après plusieurs manifestations de
l'opposition ce dernier s'autoproclame
président par intérim du pays
mais même s'il est soutenu par de
nombreux pays occidentaux
son dernier meeting à caracas attiré
seulement quelques centaines de
personnes et nicolas maduro de son côté
la bande à l'upa soldats de la nation
l'heure est venue de combattre l'heure
est venue de montrer l'exemple à
l'histoire et au monde de leur dire
qu'au venezuela
il y a une force armée la forces armées
nationales bolivariennes cohésive loyal
et unis comme il n'y en a jamais eu
auparavant
il faut vaincre les tentatives de coups
d'état des traîtres qui se vendent pour
les dollars de washington en bolivie ce
sont bien des manifestants soutenus par
l'opposition où finalement par la police
qui ont fait chuter le président
socialiste evo morales
j'aime aussi j'annonce que je me retire
de la présidence
une sénatrice de droite jeanine agnès
c'est alors auto proclamé président par
intérim
evo morales a finalement trouvé refuge
en argentine et incite à se rebeller
contre ce nouveau pouvoir
sera-t-il entendu l'argentine justement
où a eu lieu l'an dernier un grand
virage politique le président sortant
mauricio macri l'homme du rapprochement
avec les états unis est battu dès le
premier tour par le péroniste alberto
fernandez il nous allons reconstruire
l'argentine égalitaire et solidaire dont
nous rêvons tous c'est l'engagement que
je prends ce dernier aura la lourde
tâche de sortir le pays de sa pire crise
économique depuis 2001 l'équateur pour
sa part a fait plutôt le chemin inverse
élu en 2010 est le président lenin
moreno devait s'acquitter d'une
politique de gauche celle de la
révolution citoyenne de son prédécesseur
rafael correa
mais il a préféré se rapprocher du fmi
et s'aligner avec la politique étrangère
américaine
il a en outre décidé d'augmenter les
prix du carburant en octobre mesure
qui a déclenché des manifestations
monstres couvre-feu état d'urgence siège
du gouvernement déménager hors de
petites aux opposants politiques
traduits en justice
la situation devenue explosive augure
d'un probable des aveux aux prochaines
élections au chili la rue est également
venu défier le pouvoir ultra libéral en
place depuis 2010 des centaines de
milliers de manifestants demandent la
démission du président conservateur
sebastian pinera qualifié parfois de
berlusconi chilien
l'armée a été appelée à maintenir
l'ordre les violences se sont alors
multipliées pour un bilan humain est
lourd 22 morts et 200 éborgné seule
lueur d'espoir pour les contestataires
la tenue d'un référendum en avril 2020
pour réviser la constitution hérités de
la période pinochet au brésil une
nouvelle offensive de la gauche se
prépare alors que le conservateur
jaillir ball sonar au proche de donald
trump tient les rênes du pouvoir depuis
janvier 2019
libéré après avoir été incarcéré pour
des soupçons de corruption l'ancien
président socialiste lula cherchent
désormais à faire annuler sa
condamnation pour pouvoir se présenter
aux prochaines élections
quelle configuration va donc se dessiner
en 2020 tandis que les forces de gauche
s'organise et que la révolte populaire
éclate dans la rue l'influencé
américaine l'emprise du fmi les
poursuites judiciaires et les coups
d'état un front tu restes en tout cas
des menaces susceptibles de rebattre les
cartes de ce continent en ébullition
[Musique]